when we look at databases we typically
well um as we look at microservices
rather we can kind of look at it like
this we started out with a spaghetti
architecture we moved to a lasagna
architecture an interior architecture
and now we're in the ravioli stage of
microservices
now why did we do this well when we had
a monolith all of the things were
packaged together and they were all
packaged together so that we could
deploy it easily because well deployment
was hard
containers have solved this and now we
can deploy really easily with containers
so we end up with lots of little pieces
that can be deployed and upgraded and
replaced really easily
as we moved from monoliths to
microservices we did great at being able
to get our functionality into small
pieces
one of the
core tenets of a micro service is that
it owns its own data so well
here's the data store associated with
that microservice here's another data
store associated with that microservice
each microservice owns its own data it
does one small job it's easy to deploy
we can scale independent of other
content it's easy to replace and in
particular
it owns its own data
but
usually when we start talking about
microservices and in particular
databases we end up with this
we've refactored our application into
lots of micro services but
we still have one big monolithic
database
i've been the person who architects this
way but
yeah why do we do that
well
probably the most frequent reason that
we cite is because the dba said no
why did the dba say no
well unlike microservices the way we
deploy a database the way we migrate a
database is very different
users get a little bit distraught when
we just
pave over everything and replace it with
a new copy like we do with microservices
so well
as an app developer and a database
developer our jobs is to provide
value to users so we're really on the
same side of this
why else would it would we end up with a
monolithic database well because
provisioning databases is hard
it's
much diff much more difficult to get a
database in place together with the
engine the data um secure
security details authentication and
backup all of those take well
they take some care
if we end up with lots of little
databases then we need to make sure that
each of those are backed up and um
authenticated i've been on that project
where a small database went down and
we're like oh we'll we'll just pull that
pull the database from a recent copy of
the backup right
we backed it up right
right
that was a bad day
so we ended up with a monolithic
database well if we have a monolithic
database we can pretend that it's lots
of little databases
with bounded contexts a bounded context
in an application is that portion of the
database that applies to this specific
domain
let's look for example at a shopping
cart and a fulfillment both of them deal
with products
but a shopping cart's job is to show all
the pictures the descriptions it's a
read-only view of the product catalog
by comparison the fulfillment center
needs only know what is the product id
and the quantity on hand
it doesn't need access to the pictures
and description maybe not even the
product name
we can build two different bounded
contexts around the product details and
be able to expose them as
micro as bounded contacts into our
microservices
perfect
well when we can get to that point where
we have enough automation to be able to
enroll our databases automatically in
authentication strategies and also
enroll them automatically in backup
strategies we can get to i'll coin the
term
micro databases
a micro database is that database that
is owned by a microservice now if a
microservice is going to own its own
data then it may have one or more micro
databases or it may have no micro
databases in this case this microservice
here doesn't do anything that requires
storing state so it doesn't have a micro
database at all but these services each
have their micro databases
perfect
now a micro database it's owned by one
microservice other services call this
microservice to get data to get or
change data
so
now we may run into a few different
problems here how do we do a join
do i really need to call that other
microservice for each record in the
result set to be able to get the
additional data
instead let's create an event store
now this event store stores all of the
events that happen in our system and at
each stage we can publish events that
respond to the different items in our in
our task
then one or more or maybe no services
listen to those events and are able to
forward those on and take additional
actions
our reporting service the one that needs
to do the drawings can listen to all
these events those that it care about
and create its denormalized view of the
data so when it comes time to build that
report we don't need to join on a
different micro database we already have
the data that we need
another concern when we move here is
how do we store the customer record
now this customer record is owned by a
lot of different places and they'll each
have additional metadata associated with
this customer
how about a shopping cart they're the
ones that are producing orders maybe
they should own the customer record
or billing they probably have credit
card numbers stored and we definitely
don't want those leaking out of the
microservice
human resources is known for having lots
of secrets maybe they should own the
customer record or sales
they're the ones who created the
customer in the first place
well
how about if we create a new customer
microservice and a new customer micro
database that has two columns
one with the account number the second
with the primary key and that's all
all of the rest of these services can
call that customer microservice if they
want to create a new
customer or if they want to resolve a
primary key into an account number or
vice versa
all of the other details can be stored
in their associated microservices the
shopping cart can store the orders or
the last known address all of the
customer details in their own customer
profile table
same thing with billing the credit card
numbers can end up in the customer
profile and that billing customer
profile is different from the shopping
cart customer profile
in particular sales
when sales creates a new lead it may
just be the first name and last name and
phone number it may not even be a
company name and so that can store can
be stored in the sales details when
they're ready to convert that lead into
a customer they can call the customer
microservice to get the next primary key
creating that account number perfect
we've got that customer record in place
so now that we've gotten to micro
databases we know that each microservice
owns its own data now we don't need to
go wandering around the office are you
using this column are you can we remove
it can we split it
a microservice owns its own data that
micro database is exclusively owned by
that service and if the service no
longer needs it then that micro database
is obsolete and can be removed
perfect
what's really interesting is each of
these micro databases
can be optimized for the task at hand
they don't all need to be the same type
of database
said by me
right now
i like this quote
okay so let's take a look at the
different database types that we have
well there's a lot to choose from let's
take a look at each of these relational
document graph key value and we'll look
at some of the other types you may not
have heard of some of these and in
particular let's look at hybrid and
multi-model databases as well
as we look at each database type we'll
look at the characteristics pros and
cons and when it is best to use this
micro this database type
first let's look at take a look at a
relational database or a sql database we
can think of this like an excel table
the beautiful thing is that in each
table we have rows and columns
each row represents one item of data and
each column represents data that is
specific to that type in my address
column i will have addresses in my phone
number column i'll have phone numbers
so we create a relational database where
we can have these tables that start to
relate to each other
what's particularly cool is the sql
query language is really optimized for
efficiently processing these queries
next we have acid compliance let's
double click into that
acid compliance atomic it all succeeds
or fails consistent no partial
transactions isolated transactions don't
overlap and durable once it's done it's
done
with acid compliance we know that the
entire set will either succeed or fail
together we won't get a partial
transaction we won't get half the data
by comparison we could look at eventual
consistency in eventual consistency
it'll all finish eventually but if we
write and then immediately read we may
not get the right answer
for example if i walk into starbucks and
i start purchasing a thing and then i
immediately check my statement i
probably won't see that charge
but by the end of the month my credit
card statement is going to show all of
the trips to starbucks
it is eventually consistent
so here in sql we have acid compliance
we know that as soon as we finish
writing we can read and we're good to go
on the upside
relational databases have a strong
schema table joins a very optimized
engine and compatible familiar syntax on
the downside it was built in an era
where we didn't have multiple processors
working together so generally a
relational database is one big
machine
we can vertically scale easily but
horizontally scaling is hard
here's some example relational databases
relational database is a good default i
bet if you have a monolithic database it
is a relational database
next up let's look at nosql now i'm
going to specifically call this document
databases because well everything that
isn't sql is technically nosql
so in a document database we're storing
json
now this json doesn't need to have the
same schema for each document and we can
have nested fields our data may already
look like this so a data document
database may be a good fit
on the upside we can nest documents
however we'd like we have no schema on
the downside our application may assume
a particular schema which means we need
to do extra error handling in case a
field doesn't exist
and how do we query into an array
if the array
doesn't exist these are questions that
our application needs to solve and it
may make our application more difficult
on the upside we have a denormalized
schema that
a denormalized system and so we may have
we may be able to scale horizontally
really easily
on the downside we have no transactions
or joins things that we're used to in a
sql-based system
next here's some examples of some
document databases document databases
are great when i need to read the entire
thing straight away
perhaps a product catalog or a news site
or a cms given that page slug i need to
go grab the entire document including
the title the author
the story the images maybe the first
page of comments all of that will get
stored in that one document so that i
can read it really quickly document
databases are usually optimized for
reads next up let's look at graph
databases with a graph database we have
not only nodes but we also have
relationships between nodes we have a
really elegant syntax for being able to
query through these graph databases
and navigate these relationships i can
store data not only on the nodes but
also on the relationships
so how is this different from a sql
table with two foreign keys well it's
about that query syntax being able to
navigate those joins really easily
by comparison if i had a table with lots
of joins i would need to repeat that
join a whole lot of times to be able to
get the friends and friends of friends
a graph database is great for being able
to navigate those relationships but it's
really tuned for that experience so it's
not really great at other things
so for example cross table joins are not
really very performant in a graph
database
graph databases are best used for
messaging apps or social networks a
recommendation engine something where i
need to be able to navigate between
these relationships here's some examples
next up a key value database
the beauty of a key value database is
that we basically have one primary key
column and one blob that is well
whatever kind of data that we need
the blobs don't need to be the same
format or even
the same length they just get put in
place we read by key and we're able to
get that data
so it's really fast if we do queries by
id
i could use this for caching to be able
to store a user session or a shopping
cart
on the downside i can't really filter by
any other column because the data may be
different types
basically the only way to
filter by a non-key id is to iterate
through all of the columns deserializing
each in the way that it should be read
and then filtering the data there
here's some examples of key value
columns it's great for cache for
configuration for user data what makes
it great for a configuration is that the
values don't all need to be the same one
might be a string one a number one an
array of content and a key value
database does just fine with that
next up let's look at time series
databases in a time series database we
are able to select content for
and rather than just rows and columns
with each cell holding one value each
cell holds a range of values all the
things that fit within this time bucket
it's great for fast ingest of real-time
events
so with the time series database i'm
able to query events and inside that
time bucket i can do aggregate functions
like min max count i can start to
average or normalize for missing data on
the downside it's not really tuned for
anything else
here's some examples of time series
databases it's great when i'm trying to
monitor mobile devices sensors stock
trades something that is very time
centric i can pull the time in really
quickly and i can be able to bucket on
this time to be able to build for
example candlestick charts
next up let's look at text search
databases text search databases are
great for being able to identify a
particular phrase in a document or to
identify which documents match this
phrase it's often paired with a natural
language processing system and then we
end up with a search engine
it uses an inverted index much like the
index at the back of a book we'll go
grab all of the words in this document
we'll stick them in that inverted index
and we'll be able to look through that
index to find the
documents that have this phrase
on the upside it's optimized for text
and being able to find either documents
that match or the pages the content
inside the document that matches
on the downside it's really not guild
geared for anything else
so if i have any metadata associated
with that document i'll probably store
that elsewhere filter on that other data
store for those documents that have the
right metadata and then use my text
search database to find the matching
documents
there are no relationships
one of the other things inside of a text
search database is stop words
in english a and the
these words have no meaning on their own
and so well we probably exclude them
from our index just for size
in the
in another language or culture the stop
words may be different so it's easy to
accidentally get stop words that are
incorrect
here's some examples of text search
databases it's great for finding
matching documents and finding the
content within a document
next object stores
s3 is a great example of this
we have a key that is a
path and let's pretend that it's you
know files and folders but really it's
just a key we'll probably delimit it by
slashes to pretend that it's a file
system and then the value is one big
binary blob
so i might store things like database
backups or in movies or images
now the beautiful thing here is that i
can now query those by id and render
these big things in really elegant ways
on the downside i can't filter by
anything else much like a key value
store if i want to filter by
when is the last time this document was
updated i probably need to grab each
database backup in time
unzip it or untar it deserialize it in
the way that makes sense and go look for
the file within that backup i might want
to have an additional data store maybe a
relational data store that stores that
metadata associated with each file
object stores here's some examples
it's best for big things where i only
need to grab it by key
next event sourcing
with an event sourcing system i will
publish events into one side and then
consume it in another side it's great
for a published subscribe system when i
want to communicate between systems
asynchronously they don't both need to
be online and whenever that system comes
back online it can continue reading from
wherever it was
that's perfect
further i can filter this feed based on
channels or topics and subscribe to only
the events that i need to
in effect different consumers can read a
different portion at different parts and
whenever they get caught up they're able
to read that content
what's really elegant is if i change my
business rules i can reset a consumer to
be able to restart reading at the
beginning and get caught up to whatever
the new business rules are
it's pub sub but it's asynchronous i can
publish as fast as i can and consume it
whenever i'm ready
on the upside it's great for being able
to stream these events to anyone who
needs to know it on the downside getting
the current version is much more
difficult i must start at the beginning
and rebuild the entire history to be
able to get at the result but on the
upside if i change my business rules i
can replay that experience to find a new
answer
event sourcing here's some examples of
event stores
data stores it's best used to transmit
systems asynchronously when hardware
failure may be an issue here
next up column stores now this is an
adaptation of a relational model where
data is stored in columns instead of
rows on the left we have a traditional
relational database where we have data
stored in rows
on the right we have column stores
let's imagine countries in the world or
states in the country we probably have a
very limited set
so we can compress this data really
quickly which means we can load a lot of
data really fast
column stores are great for analytical
workloads where we can read bulk read
content bulk seek and then bulk read
content as opposed to transactional
workloads which would be best for a
different data store column stores are
not great at transactional processing
here's some examples of column stores
column stores are great for analytical
workloads where i want to process data
in bulk
hybrid databases we've looked at a lot
of different types of data stores and
we've seen pros and cons in each section
well what if i want something that can
do lots of things what if i have a
relational database but i also have a
json column that allows me to do
document data processing as well
what if i have a time series windowing
function inside my sql database
hybrid databases are kind of really
elegant and they start to expand our
views beyond just the type that we're
looking for
here's the spot where you should take a
screenshot grab your camera here's each
of the data stores a description of it
and what it's best used for
next
let's take a look at some of the things
that we learned today we started started
our journey from monolithic database to
micro databases we saw how in a
monolithic database we could use a
bounded context to be able to get a
micro database like experience in spite
of the fact that we only had one big
database once we had enough automation
to be able to automatically subscribe
our database into
authentication and backup schemes we can
move to micro databases and then at that
point each of the micro databases might
be whatever type is best suited for its
need
the different data stores that we looked
at are here
now what are my best practices well
ideally you should use a database as a
service let somebody else worry about
uptime and point-in-time restore and
ensuring that all of that content is
ready
if you must
then you can use it on premise but
ideally database as a service is best
if you have more than one database
server you should use automation to
ensure that your database is enrolled in
authentication and backup schemes to
ensure that you don't miss one
choose a sql database by default because
that's a pretty good
standard
sql databases have a really fast query
engine and we have acid compliance which
may be a feature that you really need
if you find an exact match in another
type of database then reach out for that
database that is exactly suited for your
need
is it a blob store is it a full text
search engine when you move towards
micro databases you can grab the data
store that is exactly tuned to your need
and if you need some features of this
and some features of that you may choose
to have multiple micro databases or
reach for a hybrid database that can do
multiple things
this has been a lot of fun getting to
share with you databases in the
microservices world if you're watching
this later hit me up on twitter at rob
underscore rich the slides are online
right now at robrich.org